[Music]
One Step you go
just outbreak in her apartment
stop cheating bro
how you doing I'm the Lyft driver that
you call Take On Me girlfriend not a
girlfriend man just an intern oh I'm
sorry the uh credit card was invalid
[__] let you hang with us because
your daddy's a client you [__] up the
first thing
come in
there you go wow
I heard about these I've never seen one
before yeah well now you have yeah look
pay yourself whatever and uh give
yourself a nice tip thank you
you're not gonna ask me if you got home
okay
she at home okay no took it to Mass
General to pumping her stomach as we
speak
what's your name
you don't know do you
this is the point where usually I'd give
you a chance to do the right thing but
not tonight tonight I'm gonna need your
cameras
cell phones anything you might have used
to record what you did there
[Music]
foreign
pops
thank you
get up
I'm still crying now give me your phone
right or left
handed are you right or left-handed
right call 9-1-1
tell them the truth about what happened
in there tonight your daddy's money's
not gonna save you this time you
understand yes sir you know what name
no
her name is Amy give me your left hand
give me
I expect a five-star rating you
understand
yes sir knock the me though for who
Amy that's right fools
[Applause]
okay so I get a five-star rating Junior
all right
[Music]